hey bro grab a seat man grabber see so
you are designated went to serviced
accommodation King tonight then he here
let's do it let's do it how many rental
serviced accommodation deals have you
got I personally have two and I get them
emailed to me from an agent now made a
relationship with so our package around
for a month
Wow so you've got to personally and how
much money are you making just from
those two rents are serviced
accommodation deals minimum free grand
the month Wow so two deals three grand a
month
what's your secret John the truth yeah
it was the Academy
honestly it was that's great and I
appreciate you all you honoring
following that and these you'll notice
anyone on the academy raves and raves
about the Academy nurse but you know
even this crash question order at our
hot I don't really advertise these
programs all my programs are not
advertised and why don't I advertise
them I'll do YouTube it's upon us but I
don't we don't spend loads of money on
Facebook ads and stuff because we have
all these guys evangelizing we call them
the financial evangelists I just go
around Evangelos everyone you can tell
you know so so what happened in on the
Academy what what how did you go from
you know you're a DJ right yeah I was a
I was a full-time DJ I didn't let's go
in no qualifications I didn't get kicked
out but I wasn't really good at school
no qualifications left I went straight
into DJing I was a full-time DJ for six
years and then got kind of dragged to a
crash course and my sister and then
signed up to the academy straight away I
looked at rent to essays when when I
started the economy and it was just
persistence you know you learn about how
to do rent to essays in in detail on on
the academy and after went on that
training day I was ringing agents and
speaking to people so much how many
knows did you get before you got a yes
160 yeah
now the truth is is that he got 160 nose
but he was saying the complete wrong
thing it's normal to get 10 nose people
say it doesn't work because I had three
nose no no no you just need to speak to
more people but you need to speak to
more people but you also need to have
the skill what Ricky did was he signed
up for the Academy and basically the
Academy is like a series of training
programs on all these different
strategies and he signed it for the
Academy and he started trying to do a
deal before he'd even did his training
so you're like ringing all these agents
saying all the wrong thing getting told
the laser knows what did you say now we
want to know the exact friggin script
that you say now when you phone an agent
okay so you want to do role playing
we're gonna role play
Sam you're from Bairstow he's not gonna
help hi there Samuel hope you're well my
name is Ricky I'm looking to invest in
the area and I've seen online you've got
some apartments and that are going for
rent yeah you've got some one and two
bad ones is that is that right yeah yeah
we've got Walker Avenue we've got we've
got three available at the moment yeah
are brilliant and and what's all
condition of these these apartments are
in good condition well yeah the
developers only just you know just new
build so they're there they're brand new
and yeah look nice high-end high-end
apartments okay brilliant
well what I'm looking to do is I work
with businesses in the area and really
closely and what I do is I put up their
directors and staff in our accommodation
so what I can do is guarantee you guys
the rent guaranteed landlord the rent
every single month you won't have any
void periods and I'll take on the
property on a corporate let if you guys
do corporate let's that's fine and I'll
just put my clients in there directors
and if there are any void periods for me
and then I'll just put it on like Airbnb
and booking com just so I fill my gas
but you're guaranteed your rent is that
something you know you guys are open to
yeah we have a few people call but about
this sort of thing it's it's it's not
really something that I don't think
we've really familiar with I mean I
could duck a talk to the landlord and
and say but I'm not you know no promises
yeah now completely understand that have
a word with the landlords as I said is
completely hassle-free for you guys
you'll guaranteed the rent no
maintenance guaranteed rent every single
month will take you off your hands and
I'm looking for a long long term let's
as well
some how to take on a long term period
and and we'll have a good relationship
with that what's the name of your
company MP apartments yes yeah we have a
website you can visit if if you're
interested in you open to it I can send
you an email with our website our
company details and some bullet points
of what we do and then you can get back
to me let me know your for so we can go
from there yeah you drop us an email
those very info out best to Avis calm
and I'll have a look for sure I'll speak
to the landlords and give you a call
back if he's interested brilliant thank
you very much so how did he do guys you
do well yes this is what he was like
before well do together and I'll do what
he did hello this is man dual lens
limited how can I help you oh wait
you're ringing me sorry sorry you want
me to do that how was before okay let me
ring you let me ring you okay sorry hi
Samuel hope you're okay I'm looking for
some apartments use a service
accommodation I'll give you the rent
every single month I'll take care of it
if I'm just looking for ya my name is
Bill and I'm just cool yeah I'm just
looking for some you know service
combinations where we go I can guarantee
you the rent every month and you'll get
your money every single month and it's
just service combination I'm just really
looking like this but I mean yeah
you can you see you see the difference
and he was actually worse than that so
grab a seat so that's the thing it's
like scale and numbers so don't go any
questions for Ricky on or mentally yes
ma'am
how did you get your tenants how do I
get my tenants so I use a channel
manager and which I pay a fee for and
it's a yearly annual fee that you pay
would you like me to tell you my channel
manager you don't know no they don't
want to know okay so I use a channel
manager called a VEVO Evi i double ivo
and my advice would be to you guys if
you get if you want something systemized
and you're gonna make profit from it pay
to get it systemized because you know it
takes a hassle for your hands so I use a
VEVO and what they do is they'll promote
my Apartments on booking.com Airbnb all
of the online travel agencies and it's
they have a diary that synchronized so
whenever someone books on Airbnb it will
go on to my VEVO diary
they take the payments and then every
month they'll pay me so I just pay them
a yearly fee it's not a lot I stock 100
and things like 142 pounds a year and a
1 or 50 pound connection fee and they
put it on all of the online travel
agencies and all you've got to do is
upload your pictures description of the
apartment you do all that once and then
that's it they'll just promote it on
there for you yeah it's a what the fee
yeah so the 100 don't quote me on this
it's around 100 voice and pound a year
per property yes so if you've got if
I've got two apartments it's a hundred
forty-seven pound each per year so
you're three thousand pound a month is
that profit after all costs yeah
so profit yes all right there's no
reason to use corporate let's instead of
management agreements they're very
similar anyway is the if I'm going to
the landlord direct I'll use a
management contract if I'm going for an
agency they or if they open to it they
often provide you of a company
just make sure you read through it to
make sure that like there's brake
clauses and stuff but then if you go for
agencies they loft them give you a
company let already done you just have
to read through and check and make sure
you're happy with it and make sure you
have a break clause in every time I look
at SAS they have to have a break cause
at minimum six months if they don't do
break clause at six months then I won't
do it
but a lot of them you can do a six-month
contract and then you can just be month
month after but they provide the
corporate let's and the contracts if
it's alright to landlord then I'll do a
management contract that I'll provide
myself ok mmm the break clause where six
months is it for both of you only only
for you now for both both Pete it's got
yet both parties I have to be happy the
landlord has to be happy and if one of
one of us isn't isn't fair if it's just
for me because if he's not happy you
can't get out of it so it's always for
both parties to make it fair because
because sometimes everyone's got
different concerns
the landlord's concerned is usually that
he'll either won't get his rent or that
people would have and loads of parties
in there and it'll turn to something
that he doesn't want but then obviously
a concern as investors is that we might
not get guests and we might be having to
pay the rent each month but we're not
we're not getting as many guests and
we're not making much profit so what
what usually happens is I only put a
three-month break closing because I find
that after within a few weeks you
normally have a pretty good idea about
whether it's going to work or not so
three months break clause and then now
after you'll just have a three year or
however however long you agree fixed
term the great thing about rental
serviced accommodation as opposed to
rent to HMO is we've a renter HMO the
tenants that you move in they're they're
moving in for a long term for a long
time so the landlord might be a bit like
oh wow you're making all that money
these people are in my property I could
make that money
where was it for rent to sa because the
guests are continually moving in moving
out the landlord just thinks I don't
really understand how they're doing that
and so I've never had a landlord get
greedy or they just they're happy with
their rent and yeah you're right because
there's so much rotation in there and
you explain it to the landlord a minor
for agencies but I've met the landlord
and when I explained it she
just like it sounds way too complicated
but I do wish you all the best and as
long as I get my rent I'm happy and as
long as it's in good condition after
enduring but the thing is a lot of pee a
lot you'll get a lot on an Lord say well
the condition will deteriorate quicker
than it will with tenants but it won't
because from looking at from experience
and speak to other people if you have
tenants in a property it's more likely
to get wear and tear than you would with
a service accommodation and it's only in
our best interest as investors and
people that run these service
accommodations to keep them at the best
condition because we want to be able to
get guests in there so I hope that
answers your question sorry one last one
is old unum sorry would you what time of
year do you think it's best is there
like busy and quiet periods right here
yeah I would highly recommend if you've
got service accommodations make sure I
do mine I do my rates for the year but
make sure you go it's a mine Ramon
Keynes you want to go and go Google go
to Milton Keynes events and see what
events want so for example silver stones
coming up in July which isn't far from
Milton Keynes so my nightly rate of the
minute is about 120 pounds when silver
stands on is 450 a night because all the
other apartments are charged in that and
if you don't check for the whole year
every single event you could lose out
money but a vivo and the management
companies they'll check all this for you
and they'll tell you what to set the
prices for it sounds like a lot of work
but when you do it properly it actually
really isn't and it's one of the fastest
ways if you do it properly it's one of
the fastest ways to make very fast high
cash flow starting with pretty much
nothing once you set it up once and you
do it correctly and if you use a
management company and cleaners and you
have it systemized I haven't done
anything with my rents and I say is in
about two and a half months I haven't
been now and spoke to the man I've not
done anything but I've just been keep
getting paid from the work I put in at
the start
fantastic Frank's a lawyer I have a
two-part question if you don't mind so
my first one is how do you do it
properly so what types of things you
need to have in place to make sure that
okay I'll give you I'll give you three
points that I always go by to make us
have it systemized the first one's not
really systemize but it's important
just make sure it's in a good location
you want it in a city center around
University well not around you around
public transport in walking distance to
train stations airports are quite good
because you can speak to like Airlines
to put their stuff in it but just make
sure it's in a good central location in
a busy town or city to systemize it you
want your channel manager and then I use
the management company so you can use a
management company or you can just hire
like a cleaning company and you the
Aviva will have a diary so all I've done
is given my management company a
password to log into my VEVO account and
then every book and that comes in my
management company see it and they sort
out the check-in and check-out and they
put in the cleaners if you don't have a
management company you can use key safe
on the side of the building to let
guests check themselves in and out and
with Aviva they send out automated
emails that you can create for guests so
if you booked you'll get an email saying
collect the keys using this code from
the key safe located here so that's
systemising your checking in and an out
service your cleaners sync to your diary
and you know say to them just keeping on
a diary you'll get notifications you
need it cleaned you know before and
after people go in and the one of the
important things is before you get
service combination make sure that the
head if you use an apartment switch
Mostar make sure the head lease allows
short legs because a lot of people get
apartments and do you guys know what a
head lease is no okay I'll explain the
head leased real quick so apartments
you've got the freeholder and the lease
holder so the lease holder own is the
owner of the apartment and the
freeholder owns the land and the block
if you like so the freer the lease
holder pays a freeholder and annual fee
to own that apartment between them
there's an agreement quarter head lease
and in there it'll say what basically
the responsibilities are of the
freeholder and the lease holder and it
will say if you if the lease hold can be
short let's or not you have to check
that because if they find out you're
doing short let's when it's not allowed
on the lease they'll just shut you down
and if you [ __ ] up some money to get
it up and run you could lose it
so it's sorry especially three people
you need permission from you need
permission from the landlord he's happy
with it you need permission from the
lease as talked about and you need
permission from the mortgage company as
long as you get permission from those
three those three parties compliant wise
everything you could
there's no regulations around serviced
accommodation at the moment apart from
in some places like London where there's
a 90-day rule but most of the UK it's a
very unregulated market like over them
the contract there's like I don't
getting it through a company there's
nothing like a little bits of things
that we need to get in place to make
sure that we're complying with well
sorry so again over them their contract
and I getting it through may be
accompanied as any over like little bits
that we need to know now you just need
well you all I would have I'm part of
the property redress schema anyway
because it's good if you're all property
investors you want to make sure we party
redress scheme and data protection and
indemnity insurance but other than that
you just need to make sure you have a
solid contract between you and the
landlord and you're not to your first
question sorry three things channel
manager cleaners and a key safe as long
as you've got them free it'll be
systemized the final thing was and so
when you have such a like quick
turnaround how do you make sure the
people that are coming in
I like cleanness before the cleaners get
there what's that about the trash it
before the cleaners get a house yeah I
know it when you use the vevo you can we
take we pre authorize payments so we
already have their card details but you
come on the cross if you don't come with
John you're with Japan yeah yeah we have
the guest card details if they rush it
we charge the Morgan oh yeah it's just
courtesy horror story with notes like if
you get the location right you get your
price is right and you manage it
properly and you know I pre authorize
payments when they check it when they
book I take their card payments
otherwise or they pay upfront otherwise
they're not looking and if they trash it
I've got their card details saved and
then I'll just charge them they're
helpful yeah it's really helpful
awesome alright one more question for
Ricky go ride the very back yeah yeah
mic on him
go for it buddy what's your question so
I know that there's new regulations
coming into place in certain parts of
England where you can only rent service
together accommodation for 90 days
within the year yeah what are the ways
around it and okay solutions are there
to that problem okay you can either
change the use of the building or you
can just move area what do you mean by
change use of the building so it's I
went to rent so if it's if it's a rent
to sa changing uses a bit like if you're
if you're turning a single letter into a
multi layer it's like you need planning
permission you'll change the class of
the property so you'll need to ring up
the council and tell them I'm looking at
doing this and we quit so if you're
buying yet it's no problem to do rent -
si yeah you don't want to do that could
you rent - si just find another another
area okay cool all right is that would
you agree oh yeah I was just gonna say
move to another area like yeah you're
you're doing Cannes where do you live
Bedford which is like 45 minutes
well half hour 45 isn't even spoke to
anyone for two and a half months it's
all of our systems go doesn't have to be
there your house all right all right
thank you John man thanks so Ricky
fountain of knowledge man found in of
knowledge how about you 25 26 3 6 making
3,000 pound a month passive income
practically just off to red to service
departments you're also deal packaging
them yeah I made a I made a good sorry
how much how much how much God talking
about say I was just gonna say I made a
good afternoon 160 calls
I want such a good relationship with the
agent that got mine from he descends me
him every week that one a week you'll
send me him because he knows what I'm
looking for and then after like a week
eerie I said because I've got honestly
building rapport he knows I've got I
work with other investors I first deal
was your hardest driving the first day
was alone how much money did you make in
the last two weeks from deal sourcing
it's just saw a 10 grand
hi girls - come on Rick
Mondo's
[Applause]
[Music]